[Music]
hallo YouTube just Louis and my friends
this is guns in here welcome to the 18th
episode of my chest strap series in this
episode I'm going to show you a
wonderful trap e line in the quad gambit
from the King's gambit accepted volition
the opening arises after the following
order efore ePHI f4 he captures a fool
and now Knight to f3 if you check this
position in online database you will
find out that here
Chifa is highest Lee played mu and it
looks logical as well after the MU G Phi
not only black protect therefore pawn
but later on he can always push forward
on the Kings side with g4 and gain more
space on the Kings side against this
White has tried many moves but the very
tricky mu I am going to suggest in this
video is Knight to c3 and at first said
it looks like White has made a blunder
in the opening because as I have
highlighted over here black and
immediately pushed forward on the King
side with g4 and then deliver a Queen
check and yes indeed in this position g4
is the second-highest choice by the
black apart from g4 black has other
various options such as Bishop to g7 d6
all night to see 6th and against each of
them I strongly insist that you go
through the theory section and find a
good line against each of them in this
video we are going to concentrate on the
most obvious move g4 so now what is
forced to move the knight and after
Knight to e5 which attacks the g4 Black
has this little chair Queen to h4 here
g3 is forced because if you play moves
such as skin to e2 then d6 is a very
strong reply by black
so g3 what else and now obvious move F
captures g3 and it looks like white has
completely misplayed this opening and
within six more of the game white King
is in the verge of survival well yes
this position looks so much threatening
except one point that this is exactly
white once the trapping business start
with the move Queen captures g4
well if black has come this far then is
obviously going to play the move g2
check
but before we look at it the second
alternative I want to cover first is
what happens if you opponent continue
here with Queen captures g4 well after
this move might get slightly
advantageous position in almost all the
variations so for example after Knight
captures g4 in one blitz game my
opponent tried the mood defy but after
Knight to e3 pawn captures and night to
defy there's a big time problem on the
c7 and he certainly do not want to move
his King so he continued with the mood
g2 and after Bishop to g2 he defend the
c7 square with Knight to a six but the
net result is after Bishop captures
efore not only wide regain his all lost
material but black has some shattered
pawn on the King side which later on
become the easy target instead of defy
the more accurate choice here is d6 but
even after this move wide get the better
position and a simple line can run like
this
Knight to e3 pawn captures edge to rook
captures edge to Bishop to e6
Knight to defy the same problem on the
c7 square and this time around 96 is not
possible so black is forced to play King
to d8 but after the move
efore yes indeed black is upon up but
his king is completely misplaced and
else confirmed by the professional chess
engine this is an advantageous position
for white so considering all the options
we have seen so far after Queen captures
g4 I think 90% of your opponent are
going to continue here with the moon g2
check and after Queen captures h4 black
Queen will reappear on the ball and just
within the eight moves of the game black
has one whole rook so you can see the
attraction from the black side and
that's why in the database there are
more than 12 games played from this
position including few master games well
I must tell you that even though black
has a clear material advantage after
White's next reply Queen to h5 it is
white
who is coming out on top from all the
variations so the simple threat is Queen
captures f7 and then Queen captures f8
checkmate so something black has to pay
attention immediately and accordingly
Black has two different choices in one
blitz game my opponent tried to move
Bishop to d6 his idea is after Queen
captures f7 he wants to continue with
King to d8 and remain a whole rook up
but after Queen to g7 defending as well
as attacking the rook my opponent played
this tricky move Queen capture such -
now obviously you cannot grab the rook
in the corner so I continue with the
move d4 and now my opponent reveal his
nasty idea that is Queen to h4 check
well I think here might need not to
panic
and calmly play King to Devon which I
did because after few checks that is
Queen to h5 check Knight to e2 so no
more checks now and now by force white
is going to get his material back
he tried Bishop captures e5 but after
Queen check the only move is Quinn to
eight
now comes Bishop to g5 Bishop to f6 and
the forcing sequence continue from here
onwards Bishop captures f6 check Knight
captures f6 Queen captures f6 Queen to
e7 Queen captures a [ __ ] check Queen to
eat Queen to at seven after the whole
transaction we have a unique scenario
where both the King has been misplaced
but White is coming out with a pawn
advantage instead of Bishop to d6 I
think the more accurate choice here is
night 2 at 6:00 defending the f7 but
there comes d4 so now white is all set
to destroying the defender and then take
on f7
so black responds his force black has to
play d6 counter attacking White's night
but after Bishop captures at 6 pawn
captures e5 and Queen captures ePHI by
force white get his route back Bishop to
b6 Queen captures h8 and the variation
doesn't stop here because we should see
what happens if black continued here
with some accurate response Knight to d7
is forced and now Bishop captures f8 if
Knight captures afraid then Queen to
Aoife is a very strong reply so the
correct response goes from here is
castle on the Queen side and now you
just take the h7 form the most important
idea was to defend - - and the critical
sequence goes as follows Knight captures
f8 King - at 6 and now Bishop to g4
so once again it looks like black has
stopped by to castle on the queenside
and maybe he can create some attack
while white king is stuck in the center
but it is just an illusion because after
some forcing moves Queen to f4 attacking
the bishop Queen to Jeevan defending the
bishop and now attacking on d4 so white
response is force one has to play the
move defy and now it doesn't matter
whatever black plays as per the engine
the best response is Knight to g6
attacking the Queen
you cannot take f7 because of the Queen
to e3 check but instead of that White
has a better move Queen to g3 which by
force exchanged the Queen and after H
captures g3 it turns out that by the end
of this complex line fight emerge with a
two-point advantage and with accurate
play this is definitely a winning game
for the white well I hope you enjoy and
learn this wonderful trap in the quad
gambit feel free to like subscribe and
comment on my video and I'll meet you in
my next episode very soon bye and take
care